The Dashwoods were now quite comfortable at Barton,...
...and the house and garden were now familiar to them.
After two days of rain, Marianne and Margaret set off to enjoy one of these together.
They happily ran down the hills, searching for every piece of blue sky.
Then all of a sudden, the clouds came together over their heads,...
...and a hard rain fell on their faces.
Surprised, they had to turn back and began to run at full speed back to the house.
At first, Marianne was ahead, but she slipped in the wet and was suddenly on the ground.
A young gentleman carrying a gun with two dogs playing around him saw Marianne fall.
He put down his gun and ran to her assistance.
She had twisted her ankle and could barely stand.
He took her up in his arms and carried her down the hill.
He walked through the garden, and into the house, and seated her on a chair.
Elinor and her mother stood up in amazement at their entrance.
The man apologized for the interruption...
...in a manner that made him appear even more handsome than he already was.
But who is he?